and then we'll get started
okay so
okay hi everybody hi
thank you sherry it is so great to talk
to you guys
and you know the walk to end alzheimer's
is a little bit different this year so
um
ruth you and kat your co-captains of
team ruvo tell me about
uh where are you guys walking this year
how are you joining the walk what does
walking everywhere mean this year
well it it does mean walking everywhere
and so some of that for us some of it
might be from our home
some of it might be literally getting
out in our neighborhoods we want people
to do
something that to them represents
walking
and do it safely of course while still
making sure that we're getting the word
out and people are raising money
for such an important cause but so some
of our team members are walking this
saturday morning
in their neighborhood at 7 45 on a
saturday morning
some of us will not be work walking that
early
but we will we will walk or hike later
for sure
absolutely you'll be there in spirit
uh oh of course yes we'll call you
oh okay good all right
so cat tell me about team ruvo and and
how did you guys
form your team this year uh well every
year
the cleveland clinic actually has a team
and it's called team ruvo to honor our
patients and caregivers and
just bring more light to the disease
that we're trying to treat
and so we certainly know this year has
been a tough one
it's even more important to let
everybody know that we're cheering for
them
and we're going to do this in the form
of a walk so we
do want to walk our neighborhoods
decorate our neighborhoods i plan to
adorn my front yard with flowers and the
pennants
and just bring some awareness that we
haven't gone away
fighting for this disease and nancy
nelson you're on the team as well
and tell me why this is important to you
and people like you who
might be experiencing what the
alzheimer's association
is trying to do and and how uh this
is helpful to folks who may be
experiencing
the symptoms of dementia sure um
the association has been
a backbone for me diagnosed in
2013 so i have been doing the walk to
end alzheimer's
all of these years and i think it is a
way for people to get together
and to realize that they're not alone
that they do have
others and there are things that we can
do to help ourselves
one of them is walking and being out in
the fresh air
and so the group and the team rouvo
is doing that on saturday morning at 7
45
and ruth's going to be later if you want
to catch her
we i think it's important to say
we may be a little different and and it
may not be like it used to be but we can
do the things that we can do
and be grateful for that so i i am i
stand in gratitude
alonzo why is it important to you to be
part of team rouvo
well it's really important i'm going to
start my walk at desert regional center
um it's a spa for special needs
individuals
and some of them might have um also
early onset alzheimer's and i want
people to know that it doesn't
it is not just an old age
uh disability or old age um issue
it can hit you at any time you never
know so i'm going to start my walk
there and then i'll end it in my
neighborhood in henderson
so um i really want people to know that
it affects you
more than you realize you know
you may not think it will ever affect
you because you haven't experienced it
but it's an insidious disease
and i want people to know that so they
see me out walking
maybe they'll realize okay well i never
thought that it could hit me like this
it's in my neighborhood you know it's
right by um
csn so um that's the reason why i
really want to get out there especially
this year when everybody's closed into
the house
that's great ruth you experience you are
part of
support groups and you see people
caregivers
and people who experience alzheimer's
and other dementia
tell me about how it affects families
how it affects co-workers um it really
isn't just a single person's
brain disease is it no absolutely not
and i you know i started uh the walk 10
participating walk 10 to alzheimer's
when i started working at the
alzheimer's association in 2007
and and since that time in particular
i've seen how much
awareness has come out about what it's
like
and like alonzo was saying not a young
not a young person's disease
but but again understanding how many
people are affected
um it takes more than one person to care
for someone
and and if we can reach people again
early enough so that
that if you're worried about your memory
that you come and get tested early and
so if you do know again you can start
getting supports
participating in your own life and that
also among other things give you a
chance to tell the people you care about
in your community
what your wishes are um and if you
unfortunately now know
that your life's going to come to an end
sooner than you wanted
this gives you a chance again to do
those things and to
enjoy your life and to help your family
again care for you in a way that's most
meaningful to you
and to them but it is important again
that no matter where you are in this
process
that you reach out to somebody the
alzheimer's association is an incredibly
important partner for us at luruvo
we're so grateful for them and the work
we do together on behalf of families
and it's part of why we do support this
walk again we we couldn't do the work we
do
for families without them and so the
support groups are important the
one-on-one work with families if they
have questions
is just really vitally important and we
had three new caregivers at one of our
support groups just two hours ago
and so that awareness they are hearing
about it in the mail they're calling and
saying i really need it
especially right now especially right
now during covid when isolation right we
know families you guys
families get isolated from this disease
or can get isolated
and so this has just made it that much
worse so again so important that
that we get out and raise awareness but
also help the association raise dollars
because that goes for those services
that are so vital to help keeping
families safe
kat you've volunteered for the
alzheimer's association
for many years now and what is your
motivation
and where do those dollars go raised for
the alzheimer's association
during the walk uh well i started my
journey with the
association because of my family i have
a long family history
of people with alzheimer's disease and
so i became a volunteer
primarily in the public policy realm to
engage
our legislative members members of
congress
about issues facing our families and
certainly the need
for increased research funding so
the walk dollars go to help support all
these programs
that the association provides they fund
research they do
affect public policy they have caregiver
support respite care programs
education um they come at the disease in
all
areas and they're a great community
partner
that's wonderful nancy you spent a lot
of time being a liaison
between those who experience
the brain disease or the symptoms of it
and the association which works so hard
to connect and support
those individuals the caregivers and the
families tell me what that's like and
what it means to you
i think in life we have aha moments
and i've always sort of cringed a little
to think that my
aha moment was a diagnosis of early
onset alzheimer's because by helping
others we do
help ourselves and we do take a minute
to look around and see who we can help
and every person that i help
or come to me and say oh my gosh you
know i heard about you
or thank you for this or whatever makes
my day
blessed and that i know that i'm in the
right place so i don't take a second
to to worry about out there
what might be out there for me i just
stay in the moment
and and get joy from helping others and
so i
i'm i'm really i'm lucky i'm lucky and
blessed
alonso i understand you're the
cheerleader for the team
so you're gonna have to cheer this team
on
even at 7 45 in the morning on saturday
can you do a rah-rah for
yeah i really do i i i'm so proud
to work with all of these individuals
and the whole alzheimer's association
i'm proud i'm from cleveland so so
the pride comes from me my mother died
of early onset alzheimer's in 2015 my
great-grandmother we had to
take care of her so when i came here and
saw the work that kat and all of them
are doing
you know i'm just proud to be for the
the experience with them
so rah-rah
[Music]
well good luck to all of you guys i know
you're gonna have a wonderful time
and in the spirit of finding an end
to alzheimer's one day which we all work
for
so hard and uh and you too sherry
yes thank you sherry
you really are to all the teams that are
out there raising dollars
and walking in the spirit of loved ones
who have passed
loved ones who are still suffering with
this horrible disease
and those who yet are to be caregivers
or maybe go through it themselves
personally right
yes thank you thank you everybody thank
you everybody thank you
very much thank you everybody have a
wonderful walk this year
thank you thank you bye
thank you bye bye
okay